PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THEY WON'T
SEND ROCKETS THAT COULD REACH
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
>> THIS IS THE LAST ROAD INTO
LUHANSK.
PUTIN'S FORCES HAVE MOVED WITH
RARE FOCUS AND MAY ENCIRCLE THE
TWO CITIES ON THE RIVER WE'RE
DRIVING INTO.
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES WE SAW HERE
MOBILE, TENSE, AT TIMES EDGY.
AND THIS IS WHY.
ACROSS THE RIVER HERE, THE
BESIEGED CITY OF DONETSK
INCREASINGLY MORE IN RUSSIAN
HANDS, WHOEVER YOU ASK.
WE CAN HEAR THE CRACKLE OF
GUNFIRE DOWN TOWARDS THE RIVER
BELOW.
WE WERE TOLD THE RUSSIANS HAVE
TRIED ALREADY TO GET INTO TOWN,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE MIGHT BE
WITNESSING ANOTHER ATTEMPT OVER
THERE.
THAT SMOKE NEAR ONE OF THE
REMAINING BRIDGES INTO THE CITY.
OUR POLICE ESCORTS SHOUT "DRONE"
OFTEN USED TO DIRECT ARTILLERY
ATTACKS.
WE ARE ON HIGH GROUND, EXPOSED
AND SCATTER.
IT IS A TALE OF TWO DESPERATIONS
HERE.
THAT WHICH MAKES PEOPLE STAY AND
THAT WHICH MAKES THEM FINALLY
FLEE.
THIS IS THE LATTER.
SOME WHO STAY ARE INCREASINGLY
ANGRY AT WHAT'S LEFT OF THE
UKRAINIAN STATE HERE.
A YOUNG WOMAN WAS KILLED HERE A
DAY EARLIER BY A SHELL.
AND LOCALS TOLD US NOT TO FILM,
SAYING CAMERAS ATTRACTED
SHELLING.
RUSSIA'S BLOODY PERSISTENCE AND
UNBRIDLED FIRE POWER IS BRINGING
THE KIND OF VICTORY IN THE RUINS
THEY SEEM TO CHERISH.
THIS CINEMA WAS A BOMB SHELTER,
LOCAL OFFICIALS SAID.
IT'S UNCLEAR IF WHEN THE HUGE
AIR STRIKE HIT, THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY WAS AWARE IT HAD BEEN
EMPTY DAYS EARLIER.
>> JUST STARTLING HOW WHOLE
CHUNKS OF THIS CINEMA HAVE BEEN
THROWN INTO THE CRATER THERE.
THIS IS THE FEROCITY OF THE AIR
STRIKES WE'RE SEEING HERE,
DESIGNED SIMPLY TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THIS TOWN.
>> THOSE WHO STAY AMONG THE
SHARDS OF GLASS FEEL ABANDONED
ALREADY.
MANY, MANY PEOPLE, BUT THERE IS
NO GAS OR WATER OR POWER OR
ANYTHING.
WE ASK THE AID WORKERS TODAY
WHEN IT WILL ALL COME BACK.
THEY SAID THERE ARE ONLY
PROSTITUTES, JUNKIES, AND
ALCOHOLICS LEFT.
THAT MEANS THE AID WORKERS HAVE
LEFT HERE.
>> LYDIA IS CAREFULLY PICKING UP
THE PIECES OF THE AIR STRIKE,
WHICH SHE FELT THE FULL FORCE OF
IN HER APARTMENT EIGHT FLOORS
UP.
>> THERE'S AN OLD LADY ON THE
FIRST FLOOR AND ME WITH MY
DISABLED SON, SHE SAYS.
HE DOESN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
WAR IS HAPPENING.
RETREAT LINGERS IN THE EMPTY
AIR.
IF PUTIN TAKES HERE, HE MAY
CLAIM HE'S ACHIEVED SOME OF HIS
REDUCED GOALS IN THIS INVASION.
IT'S NOW THE UNENVIABLE CHOICE
OF UKRAINE'S LEADERS IF THIS IS
THE HILL ITS MEN AND WOMEN WILL
DIE ON.
THE POSSIBILITY OF A LIMITED
VICTORY THERE FOR THE KREMLIN
EDGED CLOSER TODAY WHEN
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ADMITTED
RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE GOT FURTHER
TOWARDS THE CITY CENTER OF
DONETSK AND THAT PRESSURE WILL
EXTEND INTO LUHANSK WHERE TODAY
A FRENCH 32-YEAR-OLD JOURNALIST
WAS KILLED AS HE FILMED IN AN
EVACUATION TRUCK, KILLED BY
RUSSIAN SHELLING, JIM.
>> TERRIBLE NEWS ABOUT THAT
JOURNALIST.
AND NICK, WHILE WE HAVE YOU, LET
ME ASK YOU THIS.
THE U.S. IS CONSIDERING SENDING
UKRAINE A ROCKET SYSTEM, BUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY TOLD
REPORTERS HE WILL NOT SEND
ANYTHING THAT CAN FIRE INTO
RUSSIA.
JUST HOW BADLY DOES UKRAINE NEED
THESE WEAPONS?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THEY CERTAINLY NEED SOMETHING
TO MATCH THE FEROCITY OF THE
OLDER GRANT TYPE ROCKET SYSTEMS
THAT RUSSIA USES ON AN HOURLY
BASIS, FRANKLY ACROSS THE
EASTERN FRONT THERE.
THE SYSTEM WHICH THEY'RE
REQUESTING, UKRAINE, FROM THE
UNITED STATES IS A TECHNOLOGICAL
LEAP AHEAD OF THAT, FRANKLY, AND
HAS A RANGE OF HUNDREDS OF
MILES.
POTENTIALLY JOE BIDEN'S
COMMENTS, WELL, IF YOU PARSE
THEM CAREFULLY, HE'S NOT SAYING
HE'S NOT GOING TO GIVE THEM THE
ROCKETS.
HE'S JUST NOT GOING TO GIVE THEM
IN SUCH A WAY THEY MIGHT BE ABLE
TO FIRE INTO RUSSIA.
DOES THAT MEAN UKRAINE MIGHT GET
THEM UNDER STRICT CONDITIONS NOT
TO FIRE THEM INTO RUSSIA?
CLEARLY, THE WHITE HOUSE WORRIED
ABOUT THE ESCALATORY MESSAGE
THAT COULD BE IF INDEED THOSE
ROCKETS WERE USED TO STRIKE
DEEPER INSIDE RUSSIA.
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, IN ALL
OF THIS, JIM, THE U.S. HAS NOT
BEEN HOLDING BACK IN ARMING
UKRAINE.
THEY HAVE SENT MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF STUFF AND WILL CONTINUE DO SO
IN AN INCREASING FASHION, AND
THAT'S CHANGING THE WAR IN
UKRAINE'S FAVOR, BUT HERE IN ALL
OF THIS, A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT GIVING
MOSCOW THE EXCUSE TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE FROM ONE ABOUT THEM
INVADING THEIR LESSER EQUIPS
NEIGHBOR TO ONE ABOUT THE UNITED
STATES SOMEHOW BEING MORE
INVOLVED IN THIS WAR.
>> THAT IS THE KREMLIN LINE WE
HEAR OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
STATE MEDIA, THAT THIS IS RUSSIA
AGAINST THE WORLD.
IN ALL OF THIS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
TODAY, THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER, SERGEY LAVROV,
COMMENTED ON RUMORS ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S HEALTH, WHICH
IS REMARKABLE IN AND OF ITSELF.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> LOOK, IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
THERE IS AT THIS STAGE NO
EVIDENCE THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
ANY HEALTH PROBLEMS, APART FROM
THAT YOU MIGHT NORMALLY EXPECT
FROM A MAN IN HIS 60s WHO SPENT
MOST OF THE PANDEMIC IN
ISOLATION.
ACCORDING TO THE FOREIGN
MINISTER, THEY'RE RESPONDING TO
RAMPANT SPECULATION IN THE
WESTERN MEDIA, OFTEN ANONYMOUSLY
SOURCED, OFTEN POORLY SOURCED
THEY HE MAY HAVE CANCER, OTHER
DEBILITATING DISEASES.
SERGEY LAVROV SAID NONE OF THAT
IS THE CASE.
THIS IS A MAN WHO DAILY GOES
ABOUT HIS WORK IN FULL PUBLIC
VIEW AND HE HAS NO AILMENTS OR
SICKNESSES, BUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A PRETTY SENIOR RUSSIAN
OFFICIAL HAVING TO COMMENT ON
THIS KIND OF SPECULATION IS
PROBABLY A REFLECTION, FRANKLY,
OF HOW LOUD IT'S GOT.
MAYBE IT'S A REFLECTION OF
CONCERNS INSIDE OF MOSCOW, BUT
YOU KNOW, YOU AND I, JIM,
READING THE KREMLIN IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
THERE HAVE BEEN KREMLINOLOGISTS
WHO HAVE FAILED TO DO THAT FOR
DECADES, BUT THIS QUESTION WILL
CONTINUE TO REVERBERATE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO HAVE LOON